PETER BAVNICK: What
I'm going to talk
about is the standard
APIs, machine learning APIs
that we have available that you
can start using today to make
your applications smarter.
So let's take one step back and
talk for a second about what
machine learning is.
Machine learning is a
method of teaching computers
to recognize patterns based
on examples and experience.
So it's very easy for
a child to understand
the difference between
the picture of a cat
and a picture of a dog.
But for computers this is
actually very, very hard.
So if you would start to
write rules to differentiate
shape between a
cat and a dog, you
have to build a lot of rules--
create a set of rules.
And pretty much for every set
that you can come up with,
anyone can pull
out a picture that
is not going to match the
rules that you've thought of.
So instead of writing
those rules yourself
you want the machine to learn
the rules by themselves,
and actually learn
over time and have
them become smarter as well.
And that's what
we've been doing,
and we have trained different
APIs or different models
with a vast amount of data.
And they're pre-trained
and you can use them.
So as an example
with cats and dogs,
this is a neural net that's one
of the mechanisms for machine
learning.
It gets its inputs
from its raw pixels,
image points of the image.
And with different
layers it learns
how to recognize
certain small pieces
in the picture such as
an edge, or a shape,
or that maybe the fur
is a little bit fuzzy.
So the higher you
get in the neural net
the higher level of abstraction
the neural net actually
extracts out of the image.
And at the top layer there
are only two neurons left.
We call them neurons because
this neural net is obviously
modeled after our own brains.
And the two neurons
basically specify,
is this picture of a dog,
or is this picture of a cat?
And in this case, it is a dog.
So let's do a small
experiment and try
to illustrate the difficulty of
not having a machine learning
model learning the
rules, and let's
see if we can come up with
some rules of ourselves
of a human powered
image detection.
So let's start.
So let's say we want to write
some rules to differentiate
between apples and oranges.
So what would be a
distinctive feature
that you could use to separate
the two types of image?
And you can shout out.
Color.
PETER BAVNICK: Color Stem.
Color, let's go with color.
Apple, orange greenish,
orange, orange.
Should work, right?
But what if the data that
you get is not only in color,
it's black and white?
You immediately have a problem.
And this is what I meant.
With any set that
you can bring, I
can give you a picture that's
probably not going to work.
So how about if you
add another fruit?
You have to start over again.
Because now there's a new
shape that is being introduced.
So the more different types
of data that you have,
the more complex your data set
or your rule set has to become.
OK, but that's fruit, right?
I mean, fruit, they're
all very similar.
That's actually quite difficult.
So let's make two things
that you would never think
of as these being the same.
So let's say we want to
classify mops from dogs.
Should be easy, right?
Well, maybe not so.
So this is very
difficult. Actually I
had to look at some
of the pictures,
and I'm sure some of you are
doing the same now like, well,
what is this?
Is this-- what is this?
Is this a dog?
It is a dog, actually.
So this is difficult, right?
But it even gets
more difficult. What
if you want to classify
all the images?
Everything, any object
you want to recognize it.
Anybody using Google Photos?
Yeah.
Google Photos is really,
really great at this.
And it's powered by
the same Vision API
that we're going to
look at in a minute.
So what if you not only
want to process images,
but you also want
to process video,
as we saw in the keynote?
Or you have audio, or you
have unstructured text
that you want to extract
information from?
So that's the space, and
that's the reason why
machine learning is
becoming so popular,
because it can handle
some really, really
complex problems.
So with Google we have
basically two solutions
or offerings that can help
you with machine learning.
So on the left hand side
you will see our open source
library that is, let's say, six
years of work that we've open
sourced now.
It's called TensorFlow.
It's the most popular machine
learning library on GitHub.
So if you haven't
looked at it, I strongly
suggest you have a look at it.
It's very, very powerful.
It's running many of the
machine learning stuff
that we're doing.
And you have Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
So in TensorFlow you
can define your model
and you can specify how
to train your model,
but now you need the compute
and the storage resources
where you actually train it.
And believe me, training these
models takes a lot of storage,
and it takes a lot
of compute power.
A lot of computer power.
So probably the best way
to do it is in the cloud.
And obviously we think the best
place to do it is in our cloud.
And Cloud Machine
Learning Engine does that.
It leverages our CPUs, GPUs,
and the custom built TPUs
that we've announced also.
So on the right hand side you
don't have to do any of that.
We've done it for you.
We have provided the data,
we have trained these models,
and all you need to do
is provide your sample
and we do basically
the classification
and tell you what's
in the image.
So these are pre-trained
out of the box APIs
that you can leverage
in your applications
with a single REST goal.
All right, let's start
with the Vision API.
So the Vision API is an API it
does complex image recognition
through a single call.
And one example was
already briefly mentioned
in the keynote is realtor.com.
It's a real estate
agent, and it's
using the Vision API in
their mobile application.
So when you're
looking for houses
and you see a house for sale,
you can pick up your phone,
take a picture, or you
could point your camera
at the sign that's there.
It will extract the
information and it
will pull up all the
information of the house
from the realtor.com website.
So it's just very
easy for someone just
to find the listing
on their website.
So what are some of
the features that are
available in the Vision API?
So the first most known
feature is label detection.
So basically the Vision API will
tell you what's in the picture.
Is it a dog, is it a cat, right?
The second thing
is face detection.
So it will recognize
that there are
multiple faces in the images.
It will exactly point out
where those images are.
And even further than
that, it will give you
some impression if this person
is angry, happy, and so forth.
The third one, OCR, optical
character recognition.
So basically it can understand
what text is in the image.
So it will read the text
and it will output it
in text so you can actually
[INAUDIBLE] it much easier.
It will also detect
explicit content
like nudity, violence,
blood, and it
will give you an indication.
This is a great feature
if you, for instance,
in your application you provide
your end users to upload images
but you want to prevent that
inappropriate images are
being uploaded.
Then landmark detection.
Both natural landmarks as well
as human created landmarks
are detected, and we're going to
show you what that looks like.
And last but not
least, logo detection.
So if you are worried
about copyrights,
then we can actually
detect logos in the image
and flag that for you.
So how difficult is it?
Well, I already mentioned
it, a single call.
So if you look at this
Node.js code, it's--
you have to include the Google
Cloud library, of course.
You set up a configuration
JSON structure,
and basically there's one call.
You provide the data,
you specify a callback,
because you need to handle
the response that comes back,
and that's it.
It's that simple.
So here's a picture I took
last year when I was being
a total tourist in New York.
It was actually my
first time in New York,
so I spent a day
just walking around.
And of course I had to visit
the Statue of Liberty, right?
And I took this picture.
And you can do this yourself.
These APIs have
demos on our website.
So I just uploaded this
picture on our website
and this is one that came back.
So it recognized the Statue
of Liberty correctly.
It gave it 55%
confidence rating,
and that's probably because
I'm on the back side
of the Statue of Liberty.
So it was probably missing
some distinctive features,
like the face and the crown.
But still it detected it,
it provided the location
where it is.
So that's landmark detection.
This is what you get
back from the API.
So now it's in
programming language,
it's an JSON structure, and
you can process it accordingly.
So here's the face detection.
And I would like to ask
your special attention
for the expressionlessness
of my face in this picture.
Joy is very unlikely,
sorrow is very unlikely,
anger is very-- so I
think I should pick up
poker or something like that.
But you will notice
it will accurately
provide where are my eyes?
Where are my eyebrows?
Where's my chin?
It even gives me suggestions
on where to crop.
If I want to use this, for
instance, as a profile picture,
it gives you the dimensions,
OK, you should probably
crop it right there.
That's face detection.
Then label detections is if
I push the right button--
by the way, this is
what you get back.
It's the same information,
but then, of course,
in a JSON structure.
Then label detection.
And I'm actually very impressed
with the label detection.
If you look at what it gets
from it, well, it gets a person.
Well, duh, I see that, right?
But it also noticed
people in the background.
That's also pretty good.
But look at this.
It thinks this is a vacation
picture, which it was.
Why does it do that?
I'm not really sure.
Probably the setting.
That it was the
Statue of Liberty,
and it's likely that
it was a vacation.
That there are people there,
maybe the weather was nice.
And look at this.
It picked up travel, probably
because I have a backpack.
It recognized I have a
strap around my shoulder.
So this type of information
that you get from the label
detection.
And this is what you get back
in JSON, and with the confidence
rating.
And you can act
upon it as you wish.
All right, so I
mentioned crop hints.
A very interesting feature
is web annotations,
and I'm going to show
you an example of that.
And another thing
that we recently
announced an extension of,
or an additional feature
in the Vision API is a
document text annotations.
And what that
actually does, it is
able to extract large
amounts of text.
So it's really powerful,
for instance, scanning.
Scans documents, or
if you take a picture
of a document or
a large sign, it
will process that
text correctly.
So web annotations.
What's web annotations?
So basically web
annotations provides you
additional information on
where this image resides
on the internet, who
else is using it,
and that sort of stuff.
So this car, who
recognizes this car?
Yeah, what is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER BAVNICK: That's great.
That's the car used in
the Harry Potter movies.
So it recognizes
what the car is.
But surprisingly
it also tells you
that it's in the Art
Science Museum in Singapore,
and it will also provide
that it recognizes this
is from the Harry Potter movie.
You will also notice that you
will find these types of links
here there, and these are
references to the knowledge
graphs.
So you can add an additional
API call to the Google Knowledge
Graph to even extract
more information
if you wish to do so.
So then it finds, OK, where
did this image come from?
What are other places where
this image is currently stored?
And perhaps there might
be variants of that image.
Maybe someone flipped
it horizontally,
or maybe someone cropped
it, it will still detect it.
All right, like
I said, all these
APIs you can try
out yourself for fun
on our website,
cloud.google.com,
and then for the different APIs
go to Vision, Speech, Natural
Language and so forth.
All right, so if
you're wondering
how well did Vision API with
those dogs and mops pictures,
I think it did
actually pretty well.
So it classified this one as
not only a dog and a mammal,
but it also noticed that
it's a komondor breed.
So it goes even further
than just saying it's a dog.
And for the rest--
this one also correct.
And for the rest it almost
got every one right,
so I don't know if this
one is a hit or a miss.
It's fur.
Yeah, it's fur.
But it doesn't know if it's
a dog or any other animal.
And textile, let's
say it's not correct.
So pretty good.
All right, so the second
API I want to talk about
is the Speech API.
So to Speech API
basically writes
what you're saying, right?
It's the technology
that's behind Google Home,
it's behind voice
search on your phone,
and you can just include it
in your applications as well.
And we do this transcription
in over 80 languages.
So a company that is
using that is Azar.
Azar connects currently
almost 20 billion people,
or has made almost 20 billion
connections between people
around the globe.
And they use the Speech
API in a combination
with the translation
API so that people
in different regions speaking
different languages can hook up
and can easily communicate.
So let's see a demo.
So this demo is
using the following.
It's using a command
line library called
Socks for the audio recording.
It's using a bash script,
so it's one way to do it.
We're going to see
some different demos.
This is a bash script
simply calling a REST API
through a cURL command.
So we set up a
JSON configuration
and we'll send the request, and
we'll see what it looks like.
Let's switch to the demo please.
So talking to your
machine at a live stage
is always interesting.
So as I said, it's using
different languages.
So I'm going to speak in Dutch.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
All right, so this is the
JSON that we've prepared.
You have to provide some
additional information
to the Speech API, like
what is the format?
It's FLAC.
What's the sample
rate being used?
You don't have to
specify the language.
Then it will default to English.
But in this case,
I'm providing NONL,
which is the locale
for Dutch, and I'm
going to talk about the
phrases context in a minute.
So let's see what the Speech
API actually comes back with.
That's always
interesting for me.
All right, so this
is actually quite--
this is good because this
helps me with my demo.
So it says, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So it almost got everything
right.
And that's why we have
that phrases context.
Because you might be
working with product names
that might not be very
familiar in the language.
It might be a specific name.
And in this case, the
word API, probably
in Dutch we might
say api, right?
So let's head over to the code.
So this is the code that
is running that script,
and I can give hints.
So let's add API as a
keyword to the Speech API.
So when we run it,
it will actually--
hopefully-- better
recognize what I'm saying.
All right, let's try this again.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
You will notice now that the
[DUTCH] has the API keyword
in there, and yay, success.
So now it correctly identifies
API as being a word.
So that can be used in, like
I said, for product names,
or maybe specific
words that you want
to look for in the Speech API.
All right, switch back
to the slides please.
So how difficult is it
to call the Speech API?
Well, you will see the
same paradigm every time.
The same lines of code.
You include the libraries,
set up the configuration,
do the call, specify a
callback, and that's it.
All right.
So the third API that
I want to talk about
is the Natural Language API.
So the Natural
Language API, so where
speech translates
it to text, now you
want to do something
with the text, right?
You want to see what
is the text about?
Is it positive, is it negative?
What information can I
extract from these entities
in the text?
And that's exactly what the
Natural Language API does.
So one of our
customers is Wootric,
who is using the
Natural Language API.
They provide a customer
satisfaction or a customer
survey platform,
and their customers
use Wootric's services to
solicit for customer feedback.
And they do this
in different way.
So they have a typical
scoring from 0 to 10, which
is very easy to get a sense
of, is it positive or negative?
But they also provide
a free text field.
And that's a lot harder, right?
So what is it about?
OK, you say it's
eight but is that--
what were you so
satisfied about?
So that's a lot more difficult.
They also use it to basically
do a consistency check.
So if you say a 3,
but in the free text
you're actually quite positive,
they can figure it out.
And they then can act upon that.
Also obviously, if you
get negative feedback
you want to take action, right?
So they also provide
near real time
routing off customer
feedback onto,
let's say, a contact center
where they can follow up.
They call the customer to say,
hey, we saw this feedback,
we want to talk to you.
All right, so I've taken
this from the Wikipedia.
I'm going to stay with
the Harry Potter theme.
I took this from
the Wikipedia page,
and let's see what
happens when we throw it
at the Natural Language API.
So what's interesting is it
pools Joanne 'Jo' Rowling,
JK Rowling, and also
Robert Galbraith, who
is another pen name for her
for another book series.
And these actually come
back as the same entity.
So it knows this.
And it will know it's a person.
Here again, that m-id, which is
a link to the Google Knowledge
Graph, where additional
information can be found.
British, it clearly identified
it as a location with a link
to the United Kingdom.
And obviously, it found Harry
Potter as an entity, as well.
So the second thing that
the Natural Language API
can do-- so not only extract the
entities, so what it is about,
but it can also detect is it
positive, or is it negative?
And it does so by
providing a scoring.
And the scoring goes
from minus 1 to plus 1,
indicating whether it's
positive or negative.
But it will also
provide a magnitude.
And a magnitude basically
is an indication
which goes from 0 to
infinity, is an indication.
So how many text was used to
being positive or negative?
So the more text you provide
negatively the number goes up.
And that's also very
valuable to process.
So the third thing the
Natural Language API does--
and maybe this is somewhat
helpful for your application
as well--
is it analyzes the syntax.
So the first thing it does
is it basically creates
a dependency parse tree.
So it understand
what the relationship
is between the words and how
they relate to each other.
It will provide information
on what the role of the word
is in the sentence.
So is it the root verb,
is it the nominal subject?
That sort of information.
It provides lemma, which is
done for the word help here.
And basically it gives back
the canonical form of the word.
So it will not take into account
different version of the word.
So you might have
helped, helping, help.
If you were counting
for certain words,
for instance, you don't
want to differentiate
between these versions.
You want the canonical form
you want to use and count help.
And we're going to see
that in the demo as well.
And last but not
least, it provides
additional information.
Was it plural, was it singular?
So basically
morphology information.
All right, so let's see a demo.
This demo I created
in the following way.
So basically what it's doing
is I've subscribed to Twitter.
I'm looking for tweets around
machine learning, big data,
artificial intelligence,
those sort of keywords.
I'm passing every
tweet that I get back,
I pass it into the
Natural Language API
to see if it's positive,
if it's negative.
I store this in two
Google solutions.
So one is into
Firebase database,
which is a real
time database that
can be basically I use
that to get notifications.
Whenever it's changed
in the database
I get notified in a browser so
it's very easy to see updates.
And I use BigQuery, where
I store all the tweets.
So the Firebase database
only basically keeps
track of the last one,
and the BigQuery database
stores all the tweets
that I pulled up.
If we can switch to the demo.
So here we see the front end.
So basically the tweets
are coming in live.
On the big blue horizontal
bar, you see the sentiment
that it detects, whether
it's positive or negative.
And so I ran this yesterday,
and then the numbers came back.
And I'm looking for
adjectives, by the way.
And surprise surprise, if
you look for deep learning,
big data, artificial
intelligence,
guess what the most popular
adjectives are going to be?
Deep, big, and artificial.
So well, it's working.
But it's not
senseless data, right?
So you will see that
the Natural Language
API was able to get the tweet,
understand the sentence,
extract the
adjectives, the nouns,
count the number of adjectives,
and put out this information.
I'm not showing the
tweets, because what
can go wrong showing
live tweets on the stage?
Here you see-- which is I
guess more interesting--
the scoring, whether
it's positive.
So generally speaking
tweets are relatively
positive about these things.
So that's the
Firebase, or that's
the front end on the
Firebase database.
Let's switch to BigQuery.
So BigQuery is our large
scale data warehouse solution.
And so here I store
the tweets, and I'm
going to scroll
to the right just
to prevent strange
tweets being in there.
And so I store the
tweets, I store
some additional information--
the user, time zone,
number of follow, of course,
the hashtags, very important.
But here you will notice
this huge JSON string
which is the output I get back
from the Natural Language API.
So looking at this
some of you might
wonder if I want to query this,
and we heard in the keynote
that you can use
standard SQL to query,
how the heck am I going
to query this JSON string
and look for these words?
Well, BigQuery
supports a mechanism--
and let me open the query
for you, oh, sorry--
where I can provide a
user defined function.
So you can write
your own functions
and include those
functions in your queries,
and actually we provide a
simple editor in the top
here where you can
see that I specify
the interface of the function,
basically what it expects,
and a write function as well.
So basically what
it does, it takes
that JSON, it looks
for adjectives,
pulls out the information and
returns it as a structure.
So now if I run this query
you will notice basically
the same results, right?
So I can query this information
even if it's stored as a JSON.
And the great thing is
the power of BigQuery
comes from parallelism.
So it distributes the query
over thousands of nodes,
and each node does
the simple thing.
And even these user
defined functions
are distributed
across those nodes
to perform very well, as well.
All right, if you can
switch back to the slides.
So this is how you call
the Natural Language API.
Surprise, surprise.
Same thing, set up to
[INAUDIBLE] provide the file,
set up a callback,
and that's it.
So one of the newer
features we've released,
and I hope you see
this now that even
after we released these
APIs we keep adding features
to these APIs.
So we saw the new features
of the Vision API,
here you see a new feature
of the Natural Language API.
And this new feature is
called entity based sentiment.
So instead of providing a
sentiment over the whole text,
we extract the entities
and we provide information
what the sentiment is
of that specific entity
in the sentence.
So that's more powerful.
Let's look at this example.
I really like the sushi but
the service was terrible.
So I'm positive on one side but
I'm negative on the other side.
So what am I positive about
and what am I negative about?
And that is provided here as
an example, well, positive,
0.18 is the score, and negative
for the service, a minus 0.9.
All right, look at
Translation API.
Translation API, or the
Google Translation service
is one of those very familiar,
widely used functionalities.
It supports the most
languages, 100 plus languages.
And you can use it in your
application out of the box.
So everyone knows Airbnb,
one of the customers
that is using the
translation API.
Basically 60% of their bookings
is done in a different language
than the posting was in.
And they know that
if you provide
the comments, the
conversations, the listing,
the additional information,
if you provide that
in a native language,
then the chance of booking
is much higher.
So the translation
API is actually
a very important component
of their offering.
So this is how you call it.
Same thing.
And looking at the neural
machine translation,
which is the newer version--
so basically last year
we released a new version
of the translation API.
And despite the great work
that the translation team had
done over the last eight or
nine years it was for them
I guess maybe sad to see
that by injection of machine
learning into the
translation service
it actually gained a 40%
improvement over the quality.
So imagine, we've
been optimizing,
and Google Translate was
already pretty awesome
if you compare it
with other services.
But then if you already
spent so much time and effort
in getting it so at that
level, and then with machine
learning you get a 40% bump
in the quality, that is huge.
That is huge.
So that's the power
of machine learning.
So the old way it
worked, we didn't
look at the whole context.
So basically we did a word for
word translation of the words.
And we did recognize
that there's
some relationship, right?
So if it's singular
and plural, we
will adjust the verbs to that.
But it was basically that.
And with machine
learning translation,
we actually take a
different approach.
We've trained a model with
sentences and simple sentences
to illustrate the difference
between the quality--
I've taken this from the
original Spanish text of one
of the Harry Potter books.
So when I say original,
I mean human translated.
The book was an English, it got
translated by human in Spanish.
That's what I took.
And this is the difference
between the two translation
services.
So the first
generation translation,
it said things like, a
company that made drills.
Well if it's making drills,
then it's a manufacturer.
So the proper way to say that
would be it manufactured it.
And neckless, I don't even
know if that's actually a word,
neckless.
So without a neck.
And almost twice
longer than usual.
That's kind of a weird way of
saying that in English, right?
And we've all played around
with Google translate, I assume.
And you understand
what it's about,
but you kind of go,
huh, I wouldn't send it
to my customer like that.
If you have that feeling, have a
look at Google Translate again.
Because it is significantly
better than it
was before powered by machinery.
And luckily for you,
this API is available
and it benefits from the
same improvement, as well.
All right, so with this demo I'm
going to do a couple of things.
So I'm not going to
do the speech again,
but I'm going to do the Vision.
So I'm combining APIs now.
Because I think that's
the power of these APIs.
So I'm going to provide some
text just as an example,
take it to the
Natural Language API,
then I'm going to send
it to the translation API
and see what the results are.
And I'm going to do
the same with an image.
And the image is of a resume.
So if we can switch
to the demo please.
All right, so I've
started up the demo.
So let's start with some text.
All right, it's going to
extract some information.
So I'm not going to output the
whole JSON because that will
fill the pages of the screen.
So I only took the first word,
the first entity it found,
this.
It says it's the nominal
subject of the sentence
and it provides information.
And for a lot of things,
this, it doesn't provide.
There's no gender in this,
and that sort of stuff.
But you will get
that information
for all the entities
in the word.
So we did a sentiment analysis.
Says, you are pretty awesome--
sorry, you're pretty neutral.
I was supposed to say
awesome in the sentence
and then it's going to
say that it was great.
So this is pretty neutral.
That's fine.
And the entities
found, it found demo
and it found Translation API.
Now let's send it to
the Translation API.
And I don't know if
anyone knows Spanish,
but hopefully that is a
pretty accurate translation.
Just in case, I translated the
translation back to English
so you can see what
it came back as.
So let's do this again,
but now provide an image.
And the image that
I have is this.
So this is an example of
the large amount of text
that is in the image.
That's one of the new
features of the Vision API.
So this is a resume,
it's just a sample resume
I pulled off the internet.
It has a lot of text in there.
Let's see if the Vision
API can actually grab that.
So I'm telling it I'm
providing a picture.
It senses through the Vision
API and it attracts a lot
of information, as you can see.
Let's see if it
finds any entities,
and it actually does, of course.
So there's a lot of
entities in there.
So for instance, Jane worked
at the 3M incorporated,
so I get a link to additional
information for that entity
as well.
And you'll see a lot
of different entities
that are found in the
text that's translated.
So here's the
resume in Japanese.
And as I assume none of
you speak Japanese-- well,
maybe someone does--
it comes back to English.
And you could see it it works
actually quite beautifully.
So this is an example of
combining different APIs.
So the Vision API, take
it to the Natural Language
API to extract the entities,
taking it to the Translation
API to translate the document.
So you have meta data from
the Natural Language API,
you have to translate the
text so everyone can read it
and so forth.
Let's go back to the slides.
All right, so you saw the
Video Intelligence API briefly
in the keynote and I'm
going to spend a little bit
more time about it.
So what it does, the
Video Intelligence API
is our newest m-l API.
So expect this to be
improved and enhanced
over the coming time.
What it does, it provides
information of the video
at different levels.
So it provides it at video
level, at scene level,
and even at individual
frame level.
One of the companies that
is using that Cantemo.
Cantemo is a company
that provides
services around digital
asset management.
And they love the
Video Intelligence API
because they provide
to their customers
a service where the
customers can actually
search their extensive
library of assets.
So this is a quote from
the VP product development,
thanks to the Google Cloud
Video Intelligence API
we have been able to very
quickly process and understand
the content of video down
to the individual frame
with an impressively
rich taxonomy.
So let's take a look
at what it can do.
So obviously the responses that
you get back in JSON format.
So here's an example.
It's not telling us here
what is in the picture.
It's giving us information
about the framing.
How was this frame,
this scene shot?
And this is a bird's eye view.
And as another example here,
it will recognize, look,
this is a portrait shot.
So imagine that you are a
video company and you're--
have to make video,
you can simply
search, OK, give me a
portrait shot of something,
a monkey in the forest
or something like that.
And you will find
in the vast library
of videos you will immediately
find the correct video.
I think that's awesome.
All right, let's
switch to the demo.
So here I have our demo for
the Video Intelligence API--
let me make it a
little bit bigger.
And so I have different
videos, and I can--
let's see, there was one that
I thought was funny, this one.
A tour of Google, and
let's play it for you.
So the video starts, there
are a couple of frames there.
Pictures going by.
And then it starts
as a typical video.
There are some
logos, some signs,
and I'm going to
stop the video here.
So you will notice here that
this bi-- and I actually, I
didn't see this at first, and
it's funny how your eyes work,
right?
Because I clicked on one of
the tags, which was bicycle,
and I had completely
missed the fact that there
are bicycles in this frame.
Because I was
actually my eyes were
drawn to this person
walking towards me.
And I didn't see the bicycles.
But the fact that
my brain starts
to focus on certain
things, that's
something the computer
is not bothered by.
It will just analyze the frame.
And so here you see
all kinds of tags.
So there's a
miracle right there.
We have statues.
It's found that there's
fruit, which is correct.
And I think ears here's
the bicycle, and that's--
if I can see it.
Yeah, so it takes me,
indeed, to this shot.
So I think that's
very, very powerful.
So what we can do is we
can also do a search.
Because we extracted
that metadata,
we stored it somewhere,
now we can query it.
So we saw the
example of beaches.
And I make the same mistake
because we have a simple query
there.
So here are the scenes
with beach in there.
And if you're making a
video you can decide,
do you want the first picture
or the second picture?
Different versions,
different shots,
all kinds of information.
Now let's do another
example, let's say baseball.
So when you're searching
for some videos,
then immediately from the
first line you will recognize,
oh, almost this entire video
is about baseball, right?
Because the whole line
is pretty much red.
As opposed to the last video
where only a small tidbit
is about baseball.
And if we open that
it correctly found it.
So I think this is
a very powerful way
to start working with video.
And to be honest,
this has been--
in machine learning,
processing video
is one of the hardest
nuts to crack.
Why?
Because if you look at
an image, it's static.
You look at the imaging
and you process it.
But when you want
to process video,
you actually start looking
into time difference--
sorry, the time
dimension, as well,
so you have to take into
account what is going on.
So we go further than
just individual frames
where we see someone
with a baseball,
we actually see the
movement as well.
All right, if we go
back to the slides.
So how did we build this demo?
So we're using a couple of
Google Cloud Services here.
So we store all the videos
in Google Cloud Storage.
That's our massive storage
layer for basically binary
large objects.
So we store it there,
and the great thing
about Cloud Storage
and Cloud Functions
is that you can subscribe
to changes in your bucket.
So if something
changes, like a video
is uploaded to your
bucket, it actually
notifies Cloud Functions,
and Cloud Functions
is our serverless compute
service where you can
write simple pieces of code.
And in this case, it tells the
Video Intelligence API, listen,
there's a new video
in this bucket.
Could you please process
that video with this ID?
It processes the video
and it stores the metadata
in and out our bucket.
So that is what it's doing.
Then the front end to
the demo that you see
is basically looking
at both buckets.
So it gets all the videos
and it extracts the metadata
stored in the other buckets.
So that's how that works.
So as I mentioned before, you
can play around with this.
You don't have to set up
a Google Cloud Platform
environment if you
just want to try to see
how the Vision API's doing.
Just go to one of these
websites and play around
with the demos that
are available there.
And last but not least, if
you want to get training
and you want to get certified
on the different products
of Google Cloud Platform,
including big data and machine
learning, we collaborate with
G Company to provide training.
We actually have certifications
for different levels
of Google Cloud Platform.
So there's a promotional
code for this event.
So if you go to
G Company's booth
they can provide you
with a promotional code
to get trained on these
services if you want to.
I have time for one question
if there is one question.
Yeah, so we have one minute.
So anybody-- there's
a question over there.
AUDIENCE: When you stream
data and video [INAUDIBLE]
PETER BAVNICK: No.
At this moment
that's not possible,
but it's definitely a
requirement that we've heard.
So that might be an
improvement of the surface
that we're looking at.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER BAVNICK: No
time frame yet.
All right.
Yes, and I'm happy
to take questions
offline here, of course.
That's no problem, and
I'll be here all day so
feel free to walk up to
me and ask a question.
Thank you very much guys.
[APPLAUSE]